hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 19 of my 1hour flipping challenge
today we're going to be flipping the top
100 most traded items in RuneScape uh so
this would be items like the zver scale
bow string Rune
arrows um Diamond bolt stuff like that
uh and we're going to get this right
from the Roomscape website so I hope you
enjoy and let's get
started okay guys we're about to get
started we're going to be doing 1 hour
of high volume flips uh we got the top
100 most traded open here uh it's
actually just on the RuneScape website
which is pretty convenient and yeah
let's get
started so the highest traded item of
all time or the last month at least is
the fire Rune but we're not going to do
that um at all probably just cuz the
margin is only one um I've done it
before it just doesn't doesn't really
work uh we have 20 mil in our inventory
so 127 for zver
scales two GP on zver scales definitely
do
that 30k H that will'll use that's right
there we go got our first flip on the
way cannon ball I think it's 6,000 or
something 7,000 okay and rebind them for
207 and that's another one mill there we
go 10K runes lower down a little bit we
forgot we should be reducing a bit um
because if we hit the limit we won't be
able to check it again
we haven't bought anything yet
unfortunately
149 and 143 uh pretty good so we'll do
uh what's the limit on Dart uh looks
like there's a 7K limit on Dart uh 143
and we'll definitely do 7K of
those
279 quite a nice margin on blood runes
once again 10K
runes 186 and we can sell up
for 179 another great margin on runes do
another 10k of
those one yeah perfect 179 okay 220 for
the law run
and 209 oh my God another big Marge on
that do another 10K law runes as well
and the cannonballs are all bought so
we'll sell those off that's a pretty
good margin let's have a look at that
looks like it's 22 actually although
someone in the clan chat was mentioning
something about planks being very Ed
whack well I do 10K we'll see if we hit
the limit or not there we go Z scales
all came through fortunately um we
messed that up a little bit and didn't
leave room to check I don't believe
no okay all our item and darts came
through um not too bad on that one
actually uh we just pulled out the
astral runes H cuz they were're not
buying but let's see the admin
darts 149 that would be a 6 GP margin so
not bad put those in for
149 uh 6gp on an item with 6K would be
36k uh which is not terrible anyway and
133 that's pretty good and if I recall
correctly bow strings have a 10K margin
uh so we'll do 10k of those at minus a
couple and um I think we'll pull out the
blood runes those are not buying and
okay there we go all the Death runes
have bought see what we can end up
selling those
for
270 yeah not bad actually and La runes
have all bought as well
well so see what we can sell the alarm
runes
for and all our plank spot as well
actually
216 that's a decent margin on L runes as
well
216 and uh oh planks interesting we sold
those all at once
crazy sell for
44 and I'm thinking we should probably
just buy some more more Oak planks that
has a pretty massive margin we'll see if
we get the limit for
it um but yeah we'll do another 5,000 I
think okay the adamant darts have sold
uh let's see what we got on the
darts one zero it's not in there at
all okay just like that we bought 10K
bow
strings it's not used to my offerers
completing like all at once like that
it's crazy uh 136 that will give us a 3
GP margin so 30k pretty easy um death
runes have sold uh so we got 70k there
actually pretty nice uh yeah we'll do
the astral Rune it's a 2gp margin H not
too bad
though 10K and reduce that down a
bit uh two GP on nature runes we can do
a bit of those now 10K nature runes as
always okay another quite highly traded
a is the mythal dart
tip uh which is just 103 coins not too
bad 105
into 103 um yeah do some mythal Dart
tips I'm assuming it's 10K hopefully
doesn't share its margin with the mythal
dart and okay these dollar scales are
all sold uh that would give us I guess
just 30k in profit there all right let's
do that
crazy uh is there a limit for the gold
bar 10K
all right I hope that buys maple long
Bow's unstrung actually that's a good
one Maple Longbow
unrung uh 100 into 90 that's pretty nice
uh let's have a look at the limit for
that
uh not on there I think it's 8K though
be my random
guess and we bought all the nature runes
nice and we'll plop those in sell
offer we bought them for 262 and we're
going to sell them
for
262 okay pop them for 263 and see if we
actually manage to sell them there we go
the oak planks have all sold wow all at
once um that's a 20K or 20 GP profit on
there so quite a bit on the oak planks
okay we sold um the nature runes so that
is 10K from the nature runes uh the
astral runes sold as well for 20K so not
too shabby okay the lobster actually has
a pretty massive margin on it
176 H going to cheeky undercut for that
one uh 10K 10K and there we go one more
slot available
[Music]
1129 and 111 five that's pretty decent
for magic logs uh start with I can do
500 oh wait yeah I've done some bad math
here um let's do
7K um now let's move on to something
completely different jugs of
wine nope not jugs of wine never mind
two uh so cook sharks are just a bit
better actually uh so we'll do 5K
sharks and yeah there we go got 1.7 mil
left okay we so off the cannibals there
we go got that inventory now we got more
room I would definitely be okay doing
mol glass let's see if it has a corded
bind limit uh 13,000 actually
surprisingly uh
13k and just do 12K because we don't
have the cash for 13 unfortunately okay
so I just looked at Magic logs it looks
like they're selling for a 40 GP margin
right now 11
50 um so we'll try to capitalize on that
even the amount of logs we have right
now let's just do a
calculator 1149 minus
115 34 time 2 4 67 83k in profit so yeah
uh has the potential to give us a pretty
hefty profit
there okay monkfish have a 3G GP margin
on them I do 10K monk fish hopefully we
can actually get this done in time okay
we sold off all the maple long bows
unstrung um guess we got a nine GP
margin on that so not awful okay mythal
Dart tips are gone nice um battle stabs
have a 20 GP margin in
them uh we'll do that and
700 okay so the LA runes have sold uh
didn't get much on those unfortunately
now look at this diamond bolt e what the
hell that is just crazy that's insane
there's no
way oh my God we're actually buying some
of these Diamond bolt e crazy if we
actually get the margin like that that
would be an insane amount of profit okay
we bought 700 battle stabs and um I mean
we're only flipping these for 20 GP um
but it kind of adds up pretty quickly
okay we sold up all the magic logs
finally and that's a pretty hefty profit
just on the magic logs actually so we'll
probably go try that again if we have
ton of time I probably should have
bought more H go for another
3K seems reasonable to me okay lobsters
have totally sold um Diamond bolts we've
got a solid amount of those uh so we'll
plop those in for their high price which
is going to
be 417 not too bad we are going to
undercut unfortunately
and we shall confirm that so let's just
hope we can flip these that is a let's
just check the Prof on this item
here 416 minus
331 time
8,000 oh my
God that an just just
crazy 416 still seems to be right pop
that in for 415 just in
case uh Magic logs Fair of them a bit of
them have come through
oh my God this is a lot of work I did
not expect it to be this much 1140 pop
that in there for
1139 don't enough time to be
polite battle stabs all come through so
we'll claim that and
um okay guys we actually sold all our
magic logs we claim that uh we got bit
more here to plop in there for
11398 and uh we do 5K I [__] it no we
can do in another like 10 minutes that
is kind of low risk um we did pretty
much hit the limit for the diamond bolts
but they're total almost sold it's crazy
oh my God they like instantly
bought okay
9169 uh we're getting
about 20K in each of these flips so not
like crazy uh but still steady progress
and there we go the diamond bolt tips or
Diamond bolts Enchanted totally flipped
I wish we could get
this what do we buy them for okay guys
we pretty much sold all our magic logs
in like one go we're still have six
minutes left it's been like 30 seconds
since I last
spoke okay guys we're down to 3 minutes
remaining uh we ended up just kind of
canceling the diamond bolt uh we're just
don't have that much time left so we're
going to collect everything this is just
the random crap we had in our
inventory and um so we have two things
left to sell unfortunately not selling
as quickly as they did a few seconds ago
but either way I don't think we dump
them for a huge loss so we're not too
worried okay there we go guys magic
locks totally sold and so yeah we're
down to just the battle stab all right
guys that is pretty much the end of this
one hour of flipping the top traded
items in
RuneScape um by far the best item was
that diamond bolt Enchanted and next
up maybe magic logs and then after that
who knows I must have done 10 to 20
different items um ranging from 10
to 600k in profit I guess uh so there we
go timer's done pull the battle stabs
out and we'll dump them hopefully not
for too much of a loss I hate doing
this okay so we're going to pop those in
there and look at that guys we've made
at least 1 m profit that is exciting now
again a lot of that is just from that
one flip um but not all of it like that
was 600k from there so we still got 400k
from other stuff and yeah let's have a
quick look at how much we made in 1 hour
flipping top trade items would be 1.3
mil that is crazy guys I did not expect
to make anywhere near that
amount um the flips just add up I mean I
did have one massive flip that gave me
probably half of that um but still the
runes the the bow strings did I do bow
string I don't know anyway I you saw
those items I did it's hard to remember
I did so many but um I hope you guys
enjoyed uh if you did don't forget to
hit that subscribe button should be on
screen right there for you and I will
see you guys in the next episode
[Music]